je sais que tu es triste moi aussi fut
triste
vas-y moi ce que je dois faire ok je te
fais une proposition je t'envoie la
maison de mon père franchement c'est
magnifique quand tu lis magnifique que
dire froid et humide 1
non pardon pierrick j'ai un pote de
tessa sa femme sont des bananes basel
bad est ce que je peux voir ma chambre
c'est quand même ouf que ma meilleure
amie sur la demi soeur quand même dit me
marie bat comme état décrite grosse et
moche
oui oui oui tu veux dire que si j'avais
pété lesbiennes tu aimerais bien baisés
1 a dit quoi je sais pas j'ai connu sa
nuit au [ __ ] t'es d'accord mais pour
qu'elle ne sache jamais ma belle frappe
j'ai pas rester avec composent justement
on peut se faire une petite soirée
boîte et sa soeur moi je suis son
meilleur ami ce témoin conseillère soir
soirée ça me fait plaisir de le voir
comme ça
enfin tu vas pouvoir avoir un enfant qui
se précise
j'aime bien bien pourquoi
parce que je crois que tu amorces de vie